[Music]
on this Monday night the thread of power
blackouts in Alberta how the electrical
grid was pushed to the breaking point
we've used all available power what
caused it and the potential solutions to
ease the
pressure 100 days since Hamas attacked
Israel the anger and anguish of the
families of hostages do you want a
better future or do you want the cycle
of War and the agonizing weight for
Palestinians hoping to escape to
Canada critical competition in Iowa is
Donald Trump beginning a slow March to
the Republican
nomination looking for a stamp of
approval we can't forget about Ross this
story is way too important a campaign to
honor a Canadian Soldier kicked out of
the military for being
gay global national with Donna freezen
good evening and thanks for joining us
the dangerously cold weather gripping
western Canada is expected to ease this
week and in Southern Alberta it is
already warming up
all but extreme cold weather warnings
remain in place in much of Alberta and
Saskatchewan as well as parts of BC in
Manitoba at times on parts of the
Prairies it felt like minus 50 with the
windchill Alberta sent out this
unprecedented alert on Saturday warning
of potential electricity blackouts and
then it got political so ain's Premier
announcing it was providing power to its
neighbor and Scott Mo took a shot at the
federal government saying the power was
coming from natural gas and coal fired
plants the ones he says the Trudeau
government is telling us to shut down
which he says we won't Edmonton liberal
MP Randy baso called that
nonsense power grids should be Beyond
politics especially when it's
dangerously cold Brianna carsten Smith
has our top story on the blackout scare
and what's really behind
it as Alberta slowly starts to thaw its
way out of record low temperatures its
energy system is doing the same we've
been under what we call a grid alert uh
condition that's where we've used all
available power uh uh uh to meet demand
and then um we're now having to use
backup power Thursday saw the highest
power demand in the province's history
then Saturday an unprecedented emergency
alert went out urging people to turn off
lights and appliances they didn't need
natural gas facilities have gone offline
there hasn't been enough wind to keep up
and solar is only available during the
day that's left Saskatchewan BC and the
United States to chip in to avoid
rolling blackouts but this weekend's a
reminder that of course we need those
flexible dispatchable resources that can
be there uh in these periods of need to
meet those needs Alberta's opposition is
pushing its plan to switch from an
energy only Market to a capacity one
while it can be pricier the move would
ensure capacity meets Demand on hot or
cold days but the UCP scrapped the idea
when elected without a specific look at
the mix and balance of our grid that may
or may not have solved that issue in a
province known for oil and gas about 30%
of power comes from Renewables and that
number is climbing we are so excited to
partner with Ontario power gener
an announcement Monday will see
Alberta's Capital power partner with
Ontario power generation to begin the
process of building the province's first
nuclear power reactor when we underwent
what we went through this past weekend
it really just amplifies the importance
of finding dispatchable and decarbonized
electricity and nuclear is a solution
for that Alberta saw its energy output
grow by about 133% in 2023 with the
addition of more thermal wind and solar
2024 is expected to surpass that which
will be a big benefit to us when we are
when the Grid's under a lot of pressure
during periods of extreme heat or
extreme cold as we're we're now faced
with so very positive picture for
Alberta going forward because while the
province is warming now another deep
freeze is inevitable Brianna carsten
Smith Global News
Edmonton about 12 million Canadians
including people in Alberta will get a
share of $2.3 billion in federal carbon
tax tax rebates today low and middle-
inome households will benefit the most
the quarterly payments go out
automatically to households which file
taxes in these eight provinces where the
federal carbon tax applies the amount
you receive depends on your household
size and where you live for example a
family of four in urban Alberta will
receive
$386 a single resident in rural Nova
Scotia would get about
$136 more than 80% of people will get
the money via direct deposit the rest
will receive a check in the mail the
rebates are meant to offset the cost of
pollution pricing and is part of the
federal government's goal to cut
emissions by 40% by 2030 a Coroner's
inquest began today into one of the
worst mass murders in Canadian history
11 people died 17 others were injured
when a man went on a violent Rampage on
James Smith cre nation and the nearby
town of Welden Saskatchewan the suspect
died shortly after he was arrested but
the search for answers goes on Heather
urick West is in melord Saskatchewan
tonight Donna how and why my Sanderson
was able to take So Many Lives On That
September Day are questions that this
inquest will seek to answer as a jury
Works to make recommendations to ensure
that this never happens
again a sacred Fire Burns in support of
a community gutted by loss it's been
almost a year and a half since 11 people
mothers fathers grandparents and Sons
were murdered in in a violent Rampage on
the James Smith crenation and Welden
Saskatchewan the objective is to uh have
the story told honor those uh victims
that died on that day and uh try to come
up with some recommendations that will
help prevent this happening again in the
future this process for me is very
important so I can leave that trauma
behind Daryl Burns's sister Gloria was
killed he's one of several family
members participating in the inquest
with the ability to question Witnesses
throughout the process one of the big
questions is is is uh the trauma the
trauma from the residential schools the
trauma from uh uh colon uations the
trauma from um oppression and
suppression and lateral violence okay we
need to have those addressed there's not
going to be a trial so this is the only
way that the uh the families and the
public can hear exactly what happened
and and a true public factual uh account
of what happened the details won't be
easy for anyone to hear in the weeks
leading up to the inquest families were
sh shown some graphic evidence collected
by the RCMP and coroner's office
privately it was another trauma that
burns hopes will lead to Healing
breaking the cycle of pain for
generations to come we can prevent all
these people from feeling all that
trauma and that pain and that anger and
that hurt so maybe another miles is not
created again the inquest is scheduled
to hear from 32 Witnesses including
critically the parole board of Canada
the question as to why miles Sanderson a
man with a long and violent criminal
history was paroled weighing heavily on
the minds of many in this grieving
Community Donna Heather urick West in
melord Saskatchewan tonight thanks
Heather it has now been 101 days since
Hamas attacked Southern Israel and took
hostages after that Israel began at
Siege on Gaza and today the Palestinian
health authority said 24,000 people have
been killed there since October 7th one
overnight Israeli strike on a home and
Rafa killed at Le at least 14
Palestinians including a 2-year-old girl
there was also a surge of violence
within Israel a 79y old woman died in a
suspected car ramming attack in a Tel
Aviv suburb 17 other people were sent to
hospital police say two Palestinians
from the same family stole multiple
vehicles and rammed them into
pedestrians in three separate places two
men have been arrested it is being
investigated as a terrorist attack there
have been no claims of responsibility
for the families of the more than 100
hostages still captive in Gaza the last
100 days have been agonizing and now new
information from Hamas is adding to that
anguish Danielle Hamin is in Jerusalem
where families are desperate for word on
their loved ones
Danielle Donna some of the families were
given information on their loved ones
when others were released back in
November since then there has been
nothing adding to the agony in some
cases are Hamas videos like the one
released tonight in which it claims that
two hostages both men were killed by
Israeli air strikes Israel calls it
psychological
[Music]
warfare not everyone here believes the
Israeli military's campaign in Gaza
should end
[Music]
now but they all believe Benjamin
netanyahu's time as prime minister
should W you help to sing
they're here to Mark a 100 days since
the attack since the hostages were
taken 100 days without the Prime
Minister taking
responsibility among those who gathered
outside the Israeli Parliament demanding
accountability were bereaved
[Music]
families maos Inon knows all about grief
both his parents were killed on October
7th
but don't expect him to talk about
revenge I'm willing to forgive the Hamas
it was much more difficult for me to
forgive the Israeli government where
most see a crisis SM the entrepreneur
and peace activist sees an opportunity
so only hope and a better future will
you eliminate Kamas he's heard it all
from both Israeli and Palestinian
friends that he's naive that his parents
might have been killed by Israeli
Crossfire not Hamas that peace is
impossible I tell them what does it
matter what does it matter why and what
happened and who started it on October 7
I'm I'm saying them do you want a better
future or do you want the cycle of war
the cycle of blood of hate and fear that
is been going on for a century
now gild diman is no fan of Netanyahu
but believes the country needs him to
eliminate Hamas who murdered his aunt
and who's still holding his cousin
Carmel Gat hostage I see it as a life
and death conflict not an Israeli Israel
Gaza
conflict we believe in
life and the other side a terror
organization believes in
death Gat was supposed to be released
back in November but the deal fell
through those who did make it out say
they saw the 39-year-old occupational
therapist do yoga with the children to
keep them strong yeah with fewer
hostages in captivity her family now
fears the worst we know that there are
crimes against humanity being committed
right now on the hostages both men and
women sexually assaulted
tortured it's widely believed that
netanyahu's position in the long run is
untenable able but for now the priority
is the war which has the support of the
majority of Israelis replacing Netanyahu
will have to wait Donna Danielle hamam
Jin in Jerusalem thanks Danielle there
have been more attacks on ships in the
Red Sea Hoy Rebels based in Yemen and
supported by Iran struck an
American-owned container ship off the
coast of Yemen there was no significant
damage to that ship earlier huies
launched an anti-ship cruise missile
towards an American destroyer in the Red
Sea the Pentagon says that missile was
shot down Palestinians in Canada are
scrambling to submit applications for
extended family in Gaza hoping to bring
them to Canada the federal program was
originally set up to allow 1,000 people
to apply for a permit Global News has
learned more people could be accepted
but only if they can get through the
rigorous application process Neu Gara
explains this is my family back in Gaza
in December Zara Juda was able to see
her family on a video chat after losing
all connection with them for 2 weeks so
the moment I receive a DOT I know that
they're fine but they're trying to get
connected the Canadian permanent
resident arrived here last month after
fleeing the war in
Gaza she says she filmed this video on
October 9th before her family fled their
home in the
north her father later returned to this
site their home destroyed in an air
strike there's New Hope through Canada's
temporary resident pathway offering
three-year visas to extended family
members it is a very time-sensitive
issue she's applied to bring her parents
two sisters brother and grandmother and
is fundraising to help cover the costs
this money will be used to get them out
uh find a place for them in Egypt until
they are able to arrive to Canada Ottawa
says the program's initially announced
1,000 person limit is not a hard cap
reassuring for this couple applying to
sponsor 61 relatives nearly half are
children including their newborn nephew
it's a big number then if I put the Hat
of humanity I say I can't brutalize I
can't take one and leave another take
one child and leave another child to
die as they try to help their families
they say the application process has
been confusing collecting all of this
information it is uh really um not easy
and we were lacking of um the directions
at the beginning some immigration
lawyers say the process involves an
unprecedented degree of personal details
some information is specifically
requested from 16 years which again is
unprecedented um and uh the level of
detail certainly is something I've never
seen the federal government says it's
part of a unique security screening
process which takes into consideration
the volatility on the ground all what we
need is a ceasefire we need this to stop
there's no guarantee families like hers
will be accepted or how long it could
take to know whether they
are getting out of Gaza is another
challenge something she says they wish
wasn't their only hope for survival Nara
Global News
Vancouver the first big test in the
Republican race for the White House
coming up the caucuses in Iowa how
strong is Donald Trump's hold over the
party
it is below freezing in nearly 80% of
the United States right now and 140
million Americans are under
life-threatening wind chill alerts daily
cold records are expected to be broken
from Oregon to Mississippi areas in the
Upper Midwest and parts of the Northeast
are already dealing with more than 30 cm
of snow that includes Iowa where the
caucuses are happening today as they
have every four years since 1972 in
either January or February this is the
coldest on record though with wind
chills into the minus 30s the weather
Force candidates to cancel a number of
events over the weekend and it could
impact voter turnout though former
president Donald Trump has an
overwhelming lead and his victory
tonight seems almost like a foregone
conclusion Jackson prco reports on the
vote and the race for second place in
Iowa's bitter cold there's really only
one question can anyone come close to
Donald Trump or will his Republican
Rivals be frozen out I'm caucusing for
Nikki
Haley and I don't care how cold it is I
can't divorce myself from Trump we are
caucusing for Trump down to Donald Trump
or Ronda Santos second place maybe the
only prize up for grabs in the caucuses
we can't continue to be a country in
disarray with the world on fire Nikki
Haley and Ronda santis are pulling
nearly 30 points behind Trump you're
never going to have an opportunity uh to
cast a vote that's going to have a
bigger impact most Republican voters see
Trump's opponents as Pretenders to the
throne this is after all his party in
Iowa it's not that we're the king maker
we separate the contenders from The
Pretenders it hasn't helped that the
supposed Trump alternatives are barely
willing to criticize the former
president and have already vowed to
support him if he wins the party's
nomination Trump is just such an unusual
situation partly for being former
president but partly for just being who
he is with that High name recognition
that he can run a different type of
campaign than everybody else did fearing
weather and complacency could make his
victory less than overwhelming Trump has
urged his supporters to caucus no matter
what you can't sit
home if you're sick as a dog you say
darling I got to make it even if you
vote and then pass away it's worth it a
weak performance would be embarrassing
do well enough and Trump could derail
his opponents before the critical New
Hampshire Prime Aries in one week if
Donald Trump does very very well 50% 55%
be honest he's probably got the
nomination zwn up Iowa hasn't
successfully picked a Republican
Presidential nominee in more than two
decades this time around the first in
the nation contest could be the start of
a very short race Jackson prco Global
News
Washington day of Destruction ahead lava
breaches defenses built around homes in
Iceland
[Music]
at least three homes in Iceland have
been destroyed after a volcano erupted
for the second time in less than a month
people living nearby had already been
ordered out of the area the eruption
began Sunday morning after a series of
earthquakes scientists say they weren't
intense but the flow of lava has not
stopped in Berlin Germany thousands of
farmers brought the city center to a
standstill they are angry about the
government govern's plans to end tax
breaks on farming
operations farmers are upset over plans
to raise taxes on diesel fuel as the
government struggles to balance the
budget a tax rebate on new agricultural
Vehicles will be kept but Germany's
Farmers say more help is
needed honoring history next why Canada
Post is being asked to recognize a Nova
Scotia
[Music]
veteran
a Nova Scotia woman has launched a
campaign to get Canada Post to recognize
a Canadian veteran Ross Hamilton was a
popular female impersonator who
entertained Canadian troops during the
first world war when women weren't
allowed to serve as soldiers as Heidi
petruk reports he was discharged from
the military years later a wrong some
believe should be set right with a stamp
of
Honor Canadian soldiers stared down
death in the first world War's blood
trenches making boosting morale a
military imperative that's how groups of
entertainers known as concert parties
soon formed from within military ranks
none more famous than the dumbbells and
when Ross performed with the dumbbells
he always performed as a woman Ross
Hamilton from the village of pugwash
Nova Scotia enlisted in 1916 as an
ambulance driver but made his name as
margerie and he gave them a break from
the everyday horrific realities of war
the dumbbells performed on battlefields
and stages to Great popularity when the
second world war broke out Hamilton
signed up for military service again and
again entertained in drag until he was
outed as gay in 1942 and then quietly
kind of dismissed for reasons other than
medical that reason often cited when the
military would release queer service
members at the time it's such a a
paradox because for so much of his life
um he was challenging gender Norm
but all the same he um he wasn't out and
he wasn't allowed to be out and queer
I've always felt that that was wrong at
the time it's still wrong now van vulpin
has submitted Hamilton's name to the
nation's Postal Service to turn his
story into a permanent symbol of Pride I
would like for Ross to be nationally
recognized through a commemorative stamp
with Canada Post and it also kind of
debunks this idea that queerness is a
new thing a new phenomena um we've has
been here Hamilton befriended the van
vulpin family Upon returning to pugwash
and died in
1965 she is now asking Canadians to
affix stamps on letters of support in
her campaign to recognize the wartime
role Hamilton played at personal cost
IDI petruk Global News
Halifax and that is global national for
this Monday I'm Donna FZ tonight's your
Canada is Kimberly British Columbia
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]